Доброго дня Владико Олександре, дякую, що погодились на це інтерв’ю.
Дуже приємно також зустрітись з Вами сьогодні.
Ви 16 років були особистим секретарем вже покійного митрополита Володимира,
предстоятеля Української православної Церкви.
Ви були також головним редактором офіційної сторінки Української Православної Церкви,
керували Відділом зовнішніх церковних зв’язків.
І Ви завжди мали відкриті проукраїнські позиції.
Зараз особливий час для православних, для християн України:
дні з нетерпінням чекають на Томос, інші, навпаки, ігнорують повністю новини.
Що для Вас означає цей час?
Час дуже цікавий, час історичний,
і про цей час колись я запитував у згаданого Вами Митрополита Володимира,
у якого я був секретарем. Я його запитував:
"Ваше Блаженство, а коли ж,власне кажучи,
буде повна незалежність Української Православної Церкви, чи буде вона незалежною?
Він каже: "Саша, ти знаєш, буде, але вже, мабуть, не при мені".
Так воно і трапилось. Це радісний для мене дуже шлях,
хоча і для багатьох, можливо, не зрозумілий кінцево.
Ми тільки нещодавно почали виживати з себе,
з самої нашої державності, з країникомунізм.
Ще нещодавно у нас в парламенті була дуже велика фракція комуністична.
У нас залишаються погляди про якусь ковбасу,
про те,як було гарно в Радянському Союзі.
Точно так само ми повинні вижити з себе отой старий пережиток,
котрий ми іменуємо "радянською церквою”.
Котра була і котру... Ми - за нове покоління,
це вже являється логічним, що ми переходимо до нового етапу
життя в своїй державі, за своїми правилами і в своїй церкві.
Тобто з Блаженнішим Митрополитом Володимиром Ви говорили часто про об’єдання церков?
Ми говорили і на цю тему неодноразово,
і тут можна серед експонатів побачити газету- його інтерв’ю
за 1993 рік, в якій він чітко говорить,
що нашою кінцевою метою,і в заповіті він говорив, що нашою кінцевою метою -
того шляху,по якому ми йдемо,  має бути канонічна автокефалія.
Слава Богу, я надіюсь найближчим часом ми її вже матимемо.
Згідно з Апостольських Правил, в єдиній державі, незалежній державі,
має бути єдина православна церква.
Тоді таке запитаня: що буде з Українською Православною Церквою?
Ми не можемо говорити, що вона повинна бути єдиною в адміністративному плані.
Єдиною вона має бути в духовному плані.
Оскільки Христос не розділявся,
і Церква Христова вона ним заснована
Відбувається певне адміністративне формування.
Ми маємо незалежну державу Україну, в якій,
згідно зі згадуваного Вами 34 Апостольського Правила,
має бути на певній території, котра має своє самоуправління,
вона має право мати свою незалежну православну помісну церкву.
І визнавати першого зі свого ієрархів,
тобто главу цієї церкви. Хто це буде:
чи патріарх, чи митрополит чи архієпископ - не настільки важливо,
оскільки важливий сам по собі устрій.
Вона буде рівноправною сестрою у сім’ї православних церков.
Вона буде такою як і російська церква, сербська, болгарська, грузинська,
як всі решта православні церки світу,
і ми нарешті займемо своє достойне місце.
Ви кажете, що зараз відбувається лише адміністративний поділ…
В Україні може існувати і, мабуть, так і буде
існувати декілька, тобто дві паралельних церковних структури.
Православна Церква України, яка отримає Томос і буде автокефальною незалежною церквою,
як я вже казав, у сім’ї православних церков.
І, швидше всього, Російська Православна церква в Україні.
Це те, що, мабуть, залишиться від Української Православної Церкви,
яка на сьогоднішній день є, і як Ви знаєте,
виступає проти автокефалії.
Чи будуть спекуляції щодо назви?
Я думаю, що будуть, бо вони вже є. Ми це вже спостерігаємо
достатньо часто, особливо це питання
використовується або спекулюється політиками,
котрі хочуть зберегти Україну
в полі такому впливу Росії.
Ми знаємо про заяви відомого нашого
”православного" депутата
Вадима Владиславовича.
Регулярно він говорить, про те, що будуть заворушення і військові конфлікти,
і що це приведе до кровопролиття
і що назву неможна віднімати. Але речі треба називати своїми іменами,
І якщо це Російська церква в Україні,  вона має бути Російською Церквою в Україні.
Якщо буде створена Українська церква, то це має бути Православна церква в Україні.
Є важелі, аби справді домогтись цього?
Чого?
- Перейменування.
- Перейменування?
Звичайно, є такий орган як Верховна Рада,
яка має можливість прийняти відповідні закони.
Так само, як вона прийняла звернення до Вселенського Патріарха
на основі тих чисельних прохань віруючих і виборців,
бо віруючі це також виборці.
Буде прийнятий подібний закон чи ні я не знаю.
Але я думаю, що згодом кожен сам повинен буде сказати хто він,
до якої церкви належить, хто його предстоятель.
Це процес еволюційний і в церковному житті також, поступовий.
І особливо ламати через коліно в даному випадку,я думаю, ніхто не буде,
і в даному випадку і потреби немає.
Хто скаже, що я до Української церкви належу, то він буде до Української церкви належати.
Як вона буде в установчому документі називатись,
який я надіюсь на найближчому Соборі буде прийнятий,
і цієї назви вже ніхто не відніме, бо з такою назвою буде зареєстрована
в державних органах  чи то в Мін'юсті,
чи в Мінюсті чи в Держкомнацрелігії колись був при Міністерстві культури.
Вона отримає свій документ - паспорт.
Від Константинополя це буде томос.
Вона отримає свій документ - паспорт від України.
Це буде свідоцтво про реєстрацію її уставних статуних документів.
Але зараз її не можуть назвати Українською православною церквою,
бо є ця юридична назва.
Може бути Українська православна церква,
а може бути Православна церква України.
Це дві різні назви.
Владико, Олександре, як на Вашу думку має відбуватись об’єднання церков?
Я спілкувалась з Вашою паствою, вони готові до об’єднання.
Ви підготовлювали її завчасно?
Ні, не підготовлювали. Ви коли сказали, що будете спілкуватись з паствою,
мені самому було цікаво, що будуть відповідати люди, мені самому цікаво.
скільки на проповідях жодного разу ні я, ні наші священики,
ніколи не говорили про будь-яку політику, про те,
що має хтось якимось чином
когось підтримувати, когось засуджувати.
Думка пастви у нас формується виключно
на їхній співбесіді між собою, на сьогоднішній день,
і на тій інформації,  котру вони отримують від ЗМІ.
Так, я давав дуже багато інтерв’ю
і різних друкованих матеріалів.
Всі знають, фактично, мою позицію і моє бачення цього процесу.
Коли хтось підходить, запитує, я відповідаю.
Коли хтось невдоволений, я кажу:
"Ну, у нас поки що сформована така загальна думка,
у нас є дуже багато церков, які знаходяться поряд,
якщо наша позиція вас не влаштовує, будь ласка,
ми не будемо сваритись, ми можемо паралельно мирно співіснувати і дружити.
Ви хочете поминати Патріарха Кирила,
ви хочете бути в Російській церкві -будь ласка. Ми вам цього не забороняємо,
але ми будемо жити в нашій державі, будемо в Українській церкві".
Тобто позиція дуже миролюбна.
Процес як має відбуватись?
Процес має відбуватись у Євангельському дусі: єдності і любові.
Що буде тоді з Вашим собором?
Як буде ділитися взагалі церковне майно?
Я не можу відповісти чітко на питання,
що буде з саме з нашим собором, оскільки
його власником є Парафіяльна рада,
котра і будувала цей собор за свій кошт.
Буде зібрання Парафіяльної ради, буде вирішено подальшу долю,
я думаю, що особливих проблем виникнути не може і не буде…
Тобто шляхом голосування? Більшістю голосів?
Я не можу відповісти на це питання, оскільки
Парафіяльна рада у нас одностайна
у своїй думці. А прихожани…
У нас дуже багато людей, у кожного свої можуть бути погляди.
Я ще раз повторюсь: я не нав’язую свої погляди.
Ні духовенству, ні віруючим.
Владико Олександр, Ви самі з Рівненщини.
Буквально за понад сто кілометрів від міста, де Ви народились, є таке село Птича…
Так, є таке село…
...де вже четвертий рік люди сперечаються за церкву.
Одні моляться в церковній хижці, інші - в гаражі,
в той час як сама святиня стоїть закрита замком.
На Вашу думку, як мають такі суперечки вирішуватися?
Хто має нести відповідальність за розкол громади?
За розкол громади мають нести відповідальність ті,
хто створює подібного роду конфлікти.
Наскільки мені відомо, цей конфлікт підігрівається зовні
вже багато років для того, щоб було окремим депутатом, а потім і їх послідовниками
їздити до євроструктур і розповідати, які у нас "гоніння" на православних в Україні.
Я думаю, що це питання було свого часу вирішено,
запропоновано і Юраш, директор Держдепартаменту,
їздив до Рівного. Там було знайдено компромісне рішення,
однак це компромісне рішення стороною Української Православної Церкви
не взято до виконання.
Подібних проблем... Я не думаю, що вони мають бути.
Якщо є проблема, можна використовувати спільне богослужіння.
Оприділити дні або часи,
коли можна звершувати Службу Божу.
Спочатку одна громада, потім інша.
Не бачу нічого в цьому страшного, оскільки
вся Європа живе саме за такими принципами.
Я сам служив з покійним нині Владикою Феофаном у Лютеранській Кірсі.
Нам дали в оренду,
це декілька років назад було, свято Преображення.
Приїхали зі своїм начинням, зібралась парафія,
завершили богослужіння. Нікому ніяких прикростей то не доставило.
Ми приїжджаємо в будь-яке інше місце і домовляємося
з католицькою громадою чи з протестантською громадою.
Звершуємо там богослужіння.
Це нормальні стосунки нормальних європейських людей,
котрі вміють домовлятись. Котрі поважають одне одного.
Котрі мають, повторюсь знову ж таки, права але і обов’язки.
Там паства говорить: одна церква - один хазяїн.
Хазяїн у нас Бог, а за Бога вирішувати поки зарано нам.
Повертаючись до церковного майна. На Вашу думку,
що має бути з Київською і Почаївською Лаврами?
Я думаю, що вони в якому стані і знаходились,
в такому стані і будуть знаходитись. Головне,
щоб у Лаврах не проводилась політична якась робота, агітація.
І щоб вони не перетворювались на осередки політичного впливу,
які прийнято називати в політиці п’ятою колоною.
Я думаю, що з часом, коли буде зрозуміло,
що вся та істерія і нагнітання негативної інформації
щодо незалежності Української Православної Церкви, щодо надання Томосу,
щодо буцімто використання лише у політичних цілях,
як її називає один депутат "квазіцерквою", "лжесобором",
багато чого і багато негативної риторики.
Якби ця негативна риторика Опоблоком,
точніше, окремими його представниками, я би зауважив,
не розповсюджувались заради своєї самореклами,
для того, щоб електорат, вірний Українській Православній Церкві,
перетворити на гонимих і стати буцімто
на їх захист і зробити їх своїм електоратом,
то не було б таких великих проблем, які ми маємо.
Що стосується Лавр, то там така сама братія, як і на приходах.
В Лаврах такі ж самі ченці-українці,
які живуть в нашій державі, мають наше громадянство.
З братією потрібно розмовляти.
Наші єпископи побоялося,
вірніше, мабуть, наше керівництво побоялося зустрітися з президентом,
який хотів на початку цього місяця донести до нашого єпископату свою точку зору.
Побоялось наше керівництво: а вдруг переконає!
Точно так само потрібно розмовляти на парафіяльних рівнях, донести правильну точку зору.
Розповісти, що це дійсно собор, що це дійсно канонічна церква,
що це буде церква-сестра, а не знову якийсь черговий розкол,
як його називають. Це подолання розколу
і це дійсно виконання Євангельської заповіді
про любов до Бога і до ближнього і про єднання,
якого так не вистачає Україні.
Країну й так розділюють і по національному признаку, і по мовному, і по релігійному.
Давайте хоч цей релігійний чинник сьогодні усунемо.
І ми маємо таку можливість.
Готові там слухати?
Дума,ю готові слухати завжди, дивлячись якою мовою говорити
і на мові чого говорити.
У нас на сьогодні є 53 єпархії. Відповідно, дуже багато єпископів.
Можливо, хтось у приватній бесіді з Вами говорив
про своє бажання увійти до об’єднаної церкви?
Щодня декілька телефонних дзвінків.
Це вже протягом останніх кількох місяців
запитують: а як, а коли, а що треба робити.
Я кажу: поки що зачекайте.
Для священиків і для парафій це питання не являється основоположним.
Основоположним являється для єпископів, котрі братимуть участь у соборі.
Буде створена структура, потім буде перереєстрація статутів
і ваше бажання, голосування на парафії і перехід.
А коли громадськість може почути і дізнатись реальну цифру?
Дату?
Дату і, можливо, цифру - кількість єпископів, які готові будуть увійти…
Цього поки що навіть я не знаю.
Принципово не знаю, оскільки кожен журналіст,
з яким спілкуємось, задає одне і те ж запитання.
Я дуже радий, що колись мені пропонували
поглянути на той список, котрий був поданий Патріарху Варфоломію,
кажу: ”Ні! Блаженне невідання краще всього".
Ну тому що у ЗМІ справді різна кількість,
Філарет УПЦ КП казав про 10 єпископів...
Ну він старший, йому видніше.
На зустріч до президента прийшли троє (святих отців - Ред.),
причому архієпископ Новокаховський і Генічеський Філарет
написав за кілька днів після того заяву,
що він не буде брати участь в об’єднавчому соборі.
Ну, він прийшов. Це ж було не зібрання учасників,
які мають прийти на об’єднавчий собор.
Це люди, які прийшли все ж таки на зустріч, котра була призначена президентом.
Мова не йшла про зібрання учасників Собору майбутнього.
Президент запросив на зустріч, ну ось хто прийшов, той прийшов...
То про кількість єпископів ви зараз не...
А решта, можливо, й не знали, що відбудеться зустріч.
Можливо, ще хтось хотів би прийти.
Комусь сказали в цей час, а хтось і не знав.
Подумали, якщо відмінили зустріч вдень, на 14 годину,
яка мала відбутися в Українському домі,
вона не відбулася, оскільки у цей же час, якось раптово
Синод призначив засідання Архієрейського Собору.
А в Архієрейському Соборі треба було приймати участь, оскільки це є обов’язок.
Якщо ти знаєш, що він відбувається, то ти як архієрей мусиш бути на ньому.
Тобто фактично Синод - керівництво УПЦ -
унеможливило зустріч за місцем, яке було призначене президентом.
Зустріч із самим президентом. Парадоксальна ситуація, звичайно.
Є над чим подумати і зробити певні висновки.
Ви кажете, кілька дзвінків у вас щодня буває, так?
Тобто можна сказати, що значна частина святих отців УПЦ
готові увійти в об'єднану церкву?
Так, і є багато запитань, таких, які ви задаєте...
на всі запитання я також не маю відповіді.
Коли ці відповіді з’являться після Установчого Собору,
який відбудеться і після обрання Предстоятеля,
який привезе нам з Константинополя Томос,
надіюсь, що ЗМІ більш широко і правильно
зроблять висвітлення цієї події і тоді…
Процес взагалі безповоротній - це раз.
Два: він буде більш якісний і правильний.
І останнє: як Ви вважаєте, об’єдання церков має співпасти
з реформою Української церкви?
Якою вона має бути, аби відповідати сучасним вимогам толерантного суспільства?
Як я бачу майбутнє Української церкви?
Бачу її знерадянщеною,
я б так сказав.
З відкритими дверима,
щоб можна було кожній людині
вільно отримати ту пораду у священика,
яка її турбує. Мабуть, на будь-яку тему, яка її турбує.
Але для цього повинен бути обов'язково
і відповідний інтелектуальний рівень духовенства.
Це перше, на чому хотів би акцентувати увагу і,
надіюсь, на Соборі будемо говорити про те, що
що для того, щоб відповідати на виклики суспільства,
нам потрібно самим навчитися жити в цьому суспільстві певною мірою
і стати дійсно пастирями.
Щоб пастир, коли йде попереду стада,
а паства чує голос і йде за ним. А не щоб паства йшла першою.
Її не треба поганяти, як ми інколи це робимо.
Вона повинна йти за нами чуючи наш голос нашої любові.
Можливо, Ви хочете сказати ще щось, що я не запитала?
Ви запитували про календарну реформу: чи вона буде, чи не буде.
Календарна реформа не обов’язково потрібна,
але немає ніяких перешкод,
щоб ми в Україні могли святкувати два Різдва:
за Григоріанським календарем, 25 грудня, і за Юліанським, 7 січня.
Чому кажу так?
Є певна практика, бо ми маємо багато заробітчан,
це мільйони українців, які сьогодні проживають в Європі.
Вони, відповідно, мають якісь проміжки часу -
канікули, або навчаються студенти…
Проміжки часу, коли вони можуть приїхати до України.
Зазвичай це співпадає з календарем західним,
тому для того, аби відвідати церкву й помолитися Богові,
це необов'язково має бути фіксовано 7 чи 25.
В кого получається - святкуємо 7-го, в кого не получається - 25-го.
Ні в якому випадку не можна догматизувати
і категорично забороняти, що от саме
Христос народився 7 січня, а не 25 грудня.
Христос народжується за кожною Божественною літургією,
котру ми звершуємо, і ніколи не буде лишнім
прийти в храм і помолитися Богові. Чого і вам бажаю.
Дякую Вам за інтерв’ю.
Будь ласка.